[Musique]
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean marc gabouty pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le secrétaire
d'état chargé des retraites
on peut adhérer aux grands principes du
projet de réforme des retraites régime
universel avec suppression des régimes
spéciaux système à points équilibre
financier
on peut aussi comprendre la nécessité de
mesures destinées à assurer à court et
moyen terme l'équilibré du régime actuel
avec ou sans mesures d'âge on peut aussi
imaginer utiliser le fonds de réserve
des retraites ou accélérer le rythme de
la réforme touraine sur la durée de
cotisation et bien sûr prévoir également
le financement de la phase de transition
mais en ce qui concerne la réforme
systémique qui prendra son plein effet
en 2037
c'est à dire dans 10 septembre je
m'interroge sur la compatibilité d'un
âge déquilibre prédéfinis avec un
système à points
dans un tel système en conserve une date
à partir de laquelle on peut faire
valoir ses droits à la retraite 62 ans
et le montant de celle ci est calculé en
multipliant le nombre de points qui tout
au long de sa carrière avec d'éventuels
bonification par la valeur du point
c'est une forme d'individualisation de
la retraite mettre en place un système
par points cotisé fait disparaître la
notion de retraite à taux plein et
relativise les critères d'âge et de
durée de cotisation
dans ce cadre l'introduction d'un
deuxième âge de référence avec un
système de bonus malus ne répond pas me
semble-t-il aux objectifs de cartes et
de simplicité de justice et nuit à la
compréhension de la réforme
monsieur le ministre peut-on dans le
texte de loi concernant la réforme
systémique envisagé de conserver
l'impératif des équilibres financiers et
effacer la référence à un âge d
équilibre prêts déterminés incompatible
à mon avis avec la philosophie d'un
régime à points
pour vous répondre la parole est un
monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre je le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur permettait avant de
vous répondre monsieur le sénateur de
m'excuser auprès du sénateur mais non
ville quand je suis arrivé en retard
pendant qu'il posait sa question et
c'était évidemment incorrect je voudrais
vous répondre à la question que vous
posez sur le futur système universel de
retraite que nous voulons qu'on dû
construire un mot d'abord qui permettra
de faire écho à la question qui a été
précédemment posé par monsieur le
rapporteur général
nous sommes en train de discuter et vous
poser des questions et c'est évidemment
bien légitime d'un projet de loi qui n'a
pas encore été soumis au conseil des
ministres
il est en préparation il a été soumis
comme évidemment les règles
constitutionnelles le veulent au conseil
d'état et un certain nombre d'organismes
qui sont conduits à formuler des avis
sur ce projet et il sera soumis au
conseil des ministres le 24 janvier
prochain dans les conditions qui sont
prévues évidemment par les textes
il sera ensuite transmis à l'assemblée
nationale et nous pourrons engager et je
pense que vous comme moi monsieur le
sénateur
nous sommes impatients nous pourrons
engager la discussion précise sur
l'ensemble des articles du texte
je veux donc dire n'allons pas plus vite
que la musique
s'agissant de discussion pointu sur des
articles sur des articles d'un texte qui
n'est pas encore soumis au conseil des
ministres
premier point deuxième point vous
évoquez je rappelle pour ceux qui
l'auraient oublié que si je me souviens
même je parle sous le contrôle notamment
du sénat les réformes des retraites
passée qui sont intervenus par la loi
ont je crois toujours été approuvé au
terme d'une procédure dite accélérée je
le dis pour bien montrer qu'il n'y a
rien là d'exceptionnel mais que c'est en
général la règle en la matière voilà
deuxième point e monsieur le sénateur
deuxième fois monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interrogez sur la question de la
conciliation dans un système par
répartition et par point avec la notion
d'âge des kilos car oui en effet dans le
système futur
l'âge déquilibre sera un des éléments de
pilotage du système par les instances de
gouvernance qui seront déterminés par la
loi
pour équilibrer le système et on
comprend bien l'attachement il est
souvent indiqué et j'en ai fait part
pour ma part l'attachement aux principes
de l'équilibré d'un système de retraite
et singulièrement d'un système de
retraite par répartition
l'âge des équilibres sera un de ses
éléments l'âge l'equilibre c'est vrai
monsieur le sénateur ça n'est pas l'âge
légal c'est une autre notion l'âge légal
c'est l'âge à partir duquel on peut
légalement faire valoir ses droits à la
retraite
l'âge des équilibres ce sera au fond
l'âge de départ à taux plein nous ne
supprimerons pas comme s'y était
d'ailleurs engagé le président de la
république la notion d'âge légal car
nous pensons qu'il faut laisser la
possibilité à 62 ans comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui s'agissant du régime général
aux français de faire valoir leurs
droits à la retraite
pour certains d'entre eux il est
possible
il est loisible et il peut même être
opportun de faire valoir ses droits à la
retraite à compter de 60 deux ans
pourquoi monsieur le sénateur
voudrait-on priver les français de cette
possibilité mais nous voulons créer la
shd équilibre de façon à inciter nos
concitoyens à travailler c'est vrai
c'est vrai plus longtemps de façon c'est
vrai à équilibrer le système de retraite
par répartition
ça n'est ni un gros mot ni un scandale
c'est ce qui se passe dans tous les pays
du monde mais nous voulons le faire non
pas monsieur le sénateur en utilisant
larmes si j'ose dire de l'âge légal qui
est aveugle pour tout le monde
nous voulons le faire en créant une
incitation qui prendra en compte la
réalité des parcours professionnels
n'ont pas l'appartenance à telle ou
telle entreprise ou à tel ou tel statut
mais la réalité du parcours
professionnel de façon à ce que la
pénibilité le handicap bien entendu les
carrières longues puissent être prises
en compte dans la détermination de l'âge
du taux plein de toutes ces questions et
on voit bien qu'elles sont passionnantes
et qu'elles sont sensibles de toutes ces
questions nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre à l'assemblée nationale d'abord
c'est vrai puis ensuite au sénat avec
l'ensemble des indications nécessaires
je crois mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que le débat sera riche
je suis certain qu'il sera intense et je
pense qu'il permettra collectivement
c'est bien à cela qu'un parlement sert à
produire une loi qui sera bonne qui sera
juste et qui permettra à l'ensemble des
français quel que soit leur métier quel
que soit leur statut d'envisager la fin
de leur activité professionnelle et la
période à laquelle ils seront à la
retraite avec sérénité
je vous remercie le président org et
guti oui monsieur le premier ministre je
vous remercie de cette réponse je
comprends bien vos explications
mais il ya quand même des effets qui
peuvent paraître curieux et au nom de
quoi dans un système à points un salarié
y prendrait sa retraite entre l'âge
légal et l'âge des clips serait-il
pénalisé par un malus et je dis bien
dans un système à points donc la
question que je me pose à chaque jour un
nouveau démenti à nouveau miroir aux
alouettes
une nouvelle proposition de gouvernement
qui contredit la précédente
devant une telle cacophonie qui démontre
que vous naviguez a vu nos concitoyens
insiste avec consternation à ce bar
grillage incessants sans obtenir de
réponse fiable quant à cette fameuse
réforme de retraites
on ne modifie pas l'un des piliers de
notre contrat social sur un coin de
table entre deux concertations h vivo hd
qui libre l'incitation à la
capitalisation pour les hauts revenus
et depuis hier une possible modification
de l'âge légal par voie d'ordonnancé
contrairement à vos engagements
mais de qui se moque t'on les français
ne sont pas seulement inquiets
monsieur le ministre les français
désapprouvent votre réforme et
soutiennent majoritairement les
grévistes car ils ont compris que tout
le monde y perdra même le seuil minimal
de 1000 euros que vous vous targuez
d'instaurer ne serait accessible que
pour une carrière continue au smic
le masque de la bonne gestion et de la
justice peine à dissimuler les
inégalités profondes que vous vous
apprêtez à entériner dans un projet de
loi bâclée personne n'est dû vous
rejouez en vérité la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
en mettant pied du mur les syndicats
après avoir sciemment organisé le dé
financement des régimes au travers des
exonérations de cotisations et du recul
de l'emploi public
vous appelez à une conférence des
financeurs orchestrée
pour aboutir un désaccord des
partenaires sociaux est passé en force
par ordonnance vous méprisez enfin le
parlement qui devra se prononcer en
procédure accélérée sur une réforme
tronquée de son financement
il s'agit là d'un coup de force inédit
pour le parlement une majorité de
français vous le demande
quand allez vous monsieur le ministre
faire preuve de discernement et retirer
votre texte en vers et au profit d'un
véritable dialogue social le temps de
présenter une réforme honnête et juste
aux français et à leurs représentants
bon vous répondre la parole comme
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
j'entends la tonalité hills en général
de votre question elles me paraissent
assez critique sur le projet de réforme
et je peux l'entendre je peux le
comprendre après tout c'est ça n'a rien
de scandaleux
ce qui me semble plus contestable et
pardon de le dire mais je le dis avec
beaucoup de respect c'est les facilités
de langage ou les inexactitudes qui sont
contenus dans votre question vous dites
madame la sénatrice la conférence de
financement que je j'exige ou que je
convoque mais en acceptant l'idée de
cette conférence de financement j'ai
répondu favorablement à une demande qui
a été formulée par des organisations
syndicales que vous connaissez sans
doute d'ailleurs et avec lesquels j'en
suis certain vous parlez régulièrement
mais nous avons dit qu'en effet c'était
une bonne idée de discuter avec les
organisations syndicales
un grand nombre d'entre elles ont
d'ailleurs accepté de participer
plusieurs organisations syndicales
représentatives des salariés les
organisations patronales de façon à en
effet regardé étudié formuler des
propositions qui permettent de revenir à
l'équilibré en 2027
c'est la mission qui a été confiée à
cette conférence de financement elle
commencera à fonctionner à la fin du
mois de janvier et elle a pour mission
pour objet de nous proposer des mesures
lesquelles si elles sont bonnes si elles
permettent de revenir à l'équilibré
quand je dis si elles sont bonnes si
elles permettent de revenir à
l'équilibré
et si elle respecte deux bornes que nous
avons fixés et qui ont été admises par
les organisations syndicales elle même
de nom diminution des pensions et de non
augmentation du coût du travail
alors nous les prendrons
à notre compte et nous les proposons
riom au parlement pour adoption
voilà l'engagement qui a été pris et il
n'a pas été pris par le gouvernement il
a été pris par le gouvernement les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales vous fait
madame la sénatrice
le défenseur et vous avez bien raison du
dialogue social voilà un exemple concret
pratique borné dans le temps et borné
dans l'objet sur ce dialogue social
alors c'est vrai madame la sénatrice
c'est vrai qu'un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales ne veulent
pas participer à cette conférence
donc pardon plus exactement c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales vont participer à cette
conférence mais sont opposés par
principe soit un système universel soit
un système par points
elles ont parfaitement le droit de
l'être mais nous nous sommes engagés à
créer à créer un système universel par
répartition et par point et de cet
objectif nous n'allons pas nous départir
et nous allons l'atteindre
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire
deuxième inexactitudes dans la question
que vous avez formulé s'agissant de
l'habilitation qui permettra au
gouvernement de tirer les conséquences
de des propositions qui seront formulées
par la conférence de financement vous
avez évoqué la mention et la question de
l'âge légal
vous savez très bien où je suis certain
que vous savez très bien que la façon
dont toi dont doivent être rédigées les
habilitations pour être conforme à la
constitution et le président du sénat
s'en fait souvent l'écho régulièrement
l'écho doit être désormais car c'est la
jurisprudence beaucoup plus précis que
ça a été le cas il ya quelques années
autrement autrement dit si nous voulons
pouvoir utiliser les mesures qui sont
pros qui seront proposés par la
conférence de financement il faut que
dans l'habilitation l'ensemble de ces
mesures soient mentionnées de façon à ce
qu'ils puissent le cas échéant être
utilisé tel ou tel instrument
nous devons pour que l'habilitation
puisse produire ses effets laisser aux
partenaires sociaux la totalité des
instruments disponibles et c'est à eux
qu'il reviendra de nous dire lequel ou
lesquels elles veulent utiliser
autrement dit madame la sénatrice en
ayant une rédaction
l'article d'habilitation la plus large
nous ne fermons pas le débat nous
l'ouvrons et je suis surpris que vous ne
compreniez pas car c'est une demande des
organisations syndicales d'avoir le
maximum le maximum de disponibilité pour
permettre la formulation des mesures qui
qui qui nous qui nous permettront de
revenir à l'équilibré en 2027
ce qui est un objectif convenons-en tout
à fait respectable et cuir collègues
quelques secondes
merci sur le fond vous savez bien que
sommes en profond désaccord sur la forme
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure n'allez
pas plus vite que la musique ok mais
alors par rapport à la partition et
elles sont admin il ya des choses qu'on
comprend pas ça fait quand même un
certain temps que vous pencher sur une
réforme où l'on demande un préalable à
tout examen de texte une étude d'impact
des financements et c'est simplement
maintenant que vous allez commencer à
étudier tout cela alors que les réformes
la réforme est déjà en cours je voudrais
savoir monsieur le ministre
quels sont les éléments dont on va
pouvoir bénéficier le sénat notamment
pour pouvoir prendre ses décisions en
pleine sérénité répondre aux questions
des français à savoir à quel âge
vont-ils partir et avec quels montants
de retraite
et puis répondent aux questions que se
posent chaque sénateur quel va être le
coût de cette réforme
vous nous demandez monsieur le premier
ministre 23 habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnances quelles sont les garanties
que vous allez offrir au parlement pour
vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état en
charge des retraites l'europe t3f ski
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président evo seul mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur rapporteur
spécial
rené paul savary je sais votre
engagement sur ce dossier des retraites
le fait que le sénat ait décidé ici il
ya plus de deux ans d'avoir un
rapporteur spécial sur le sujet montrent
l'engagement et l'intérêt que porte au
système de retraite le sénat je pense
que il ya un premier point qui est un
premier point de l'information c'est
vrai que nous bousculons vous avez
raison nous bousculons peut être un
certain nombre de situations des
éléments qui paraissent à qui nous nous
sommes engagés pour ce qui est de cette
grande transformation de notre système
de retraite a créé un système qui soit
universelle parlons simplement qu'il y a
une caisse commune pour nous tous que
cette caisse commune ce soit l'occasion
d'exercer une solidarité qui ne soit
plus basé sur un aspect professionnel ou
statutaire mais qui puisse permettre à
tous les français d'exercer leur
solidarité entre donc effectivement
cette dimension peut interpeller
notamment tout ce qui avait un certain
nombre de cas spécifiques autonome
cela nous le faisons avec une volonté de
créer un système plus solide car sur le
fond la réflexion qui a été menée au
sénat
c'était l'idée de maintenir notre
système par répartition et de maintenir
un système qui soit solide et durable
pour ce faire vous le savez le
gouvernement a souhaité rappeler que
l'équilibré du dispositif c'est sa
garantie dans le temps c'est sa
pérennité et c'est la sécurité pour tous
les français de garder ce dispositif
pour répondre précisément à votre
question
les études d'impact que vous attendez
car je sais que vous attendez cette
étude d'impact dès le passage au conseil
des ministres nous aurons bien sûr
l'étude d'impact et vous savez qu'elle
sera vous sera largement communiquer et
doug ont également débattre je vous
remercie
monsieur le rapporteur en et paul savary
merci merci monsieur le ministre pour
ces précisions qui nous mourrons pas
forcément rassuré le ministre
c'est simple on fait une réforme soit
avec les français soient contre les
français avec les parlementaires soient
contre les parlementaires il pour
reprendre un terme syndicale ya une
ligne rouge
si nous n'avons pas tous les éléments
c'est pas avec la même sérénité que l'on
pourra prendre des décisions et commença
sa mort c'est un certain nombre de
décisions
votre article 9 qu'un article généreux
puisque l'indexation des points va se
faire maintenant sur le salaire moyen ce
qui est tout à fait intéressant mais
comment finance-t-on par l'article dit
ce que dit l'article 10 c'est l'âge des
équilibres qui va équilibrer le système
donc faudra bien dire la vérité aux
français qu'il faudra travailler plus
pour avoir la même générosité et à
contrario et a contrario monsieur le
ministre
a contrario et bien ma foi si on prend
pas des mesures d'âge se dire tout le
niveau de pensions baissent donc
véritablement ya encore du chemin à
faire
n'hésitez pas à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour respecter le parlement
et notamment le sénat merci
si le conflit sur la réforme des
retraites équipiers un temps les
problèmes de l'hôpital public
la fièvre n'a fait que monter depuis le
mois de mars dans les services d'urgence
pour prendre un exemple dans mon
département de lot-et-garonne
l'impensable s'est produit avec la
fermeture durant quelques jours en
novembre dernier du service des urgences
de l'hôpital de la sous préfecture de
saint gaudens faute de personnel
suffisant aujourd'hui la colère c'est en
cheveux gagner tous les services
hospitaliers
le 20 novembre dernier le gouvernement a
présenté son plan d'urgence
articulé autour de trois axes restaurer
l'activité l'hôpital déverrouiller son
fonctionnement et dégager des moyens
supplémentaires le succès ex compter de
l'annoncé du calendrier ces mesures
n'est pourtant pas au rendez vous c'est
trop peu trop partiel trop étalé dans le
temps vaut la ligne de plusieurs
centaines de chefs de service
hospitaliers qui ont décidé de
démissionner administrativement pour
dénoncer les conditions de travail
détériorées
le manque de plus en plus flagrant de
moyens et les problèmes de relations et
de compréhension avec l'administration
madame la ministre nous pourrons pas
bien sûr vous faire porter le chapeau à
vendre totalement responsable cette
situation la lente détérioration des
conditions d'exercice au sein des
établissements hospitaliers publics a
commencé avec 35 heures il ya donc bien
longtemps comment pensez vous pour
enrayer cette épidémie y rétablir le
lien de confiance entre le personnel
hospitalier
l'administration et les autorités
sanitaires cette question me semble
essentiel pour ne pas accentuer une
crise des vocations déjà bien présente
pour vous répondre la parole est quand
même la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de santé madame
la ministre estime du buzz avait la
parole nous connaissons comme vous les
attentes des professionnels de santé le
cost le constat qu'ils font nous l'avons
partager et nous continuons à le
partager
et c'est pour cela que nous prenons les
mesures qu'il faut pour renforcer le
soutien aux hôpitaux des tarifs garantis
en hausse après une décennie de baisse
et 10 milliards d'euros de reprise de
dettes sur les trois années à venir des
primes pour mieux reconnaître les
soignants et rendre le métier plus
attractif dans le secteur hospitalier à
l'hôpital est versée dès ce mois de
janvier
un réinvestissement massif dans les
équipements du quotidien 155 millions
d'euros de crédits seront disponibles
dans les hôpitaux
là aussi dès ce mois de janvier et enfin
une plus grande place des soignants dans
la prise de décision dans chaque hôpital
ces mesures sont significatives elles
sont une vraie inflexion sur les moyens
après dix années de restrictions
ce sont 1,5 milliard d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires sur trois ans auquel
s'ajoute un milliard d'euros de marge de
manoeuvre supplémentaire par an grâce à
la reprise de la dette
nous sommes au delà des ordres de
grandes de grandeur sollicité par le
collectif à l'origine de la pétition
ces moyens supplémentaires permettront
aussi de reconnaître certaines
contraintes particulières par des primes
de créer des lits supplémentaires est
nécessaire de moderniser les conditions
de travail ces mesures
on changer les choses concrètement dans
le quotidien des soignants et des
patients
l'impatience qui s'exprime et légitime
et nous sommes engagés pour que ces
mesures se traduisent rapidement et très
rapidement dans le même temps je les dis
le débat doit être partagé et être
continuée c'est à ce titre que la
ministre recevra d'ici la fin de semaine
une délégation d'une partie destinataire
d'une nacelle monsieur mais deviennent
non la ministre j'entends les réponses
dont il ya urgence on espère voir des
effets rapides mais quand l'hôpital tout
se sait tout notre système de santé qui
vacille au delà des moyens financiers
les pratiques médicales n'obéissent pas
toujours aux logiques comptables au
logique administrative
je pense qu'il faut retrouver un point
d'équilibré pas arriver aux situations
dans certaines cliniques et redonner un
poids prépondérant au cme par rapport à
un pouvoir administratif
ce qui me paraît tout à fait
indispensable nos français nos citoyens
méritent une égalité de traitement par
rapport à une offre de soins de qualité
de proximité donc agissons vite ma
question s'adresse à madame la garde des
sceaux il était l isolement depuis six
mois on n'a rien pu faire avec lui
là haut nous sommes inquiets de le
laisser sortir
voilà les propos tenus par un
surveillant pénitentiaire au sujet de
flavien moreau premier jihadiste
français condamné à son retour de syrie
libéré ce lundi
il a été condamné en 2014 à sept ans
d'emprisonnement pour terrorisme
il a été libéré un peu moins d'un an
avant la date prévue malgré une
détention
parsemer d'incidents sa sortie de prison
s'accompagne d'une double mesures de
surveillance judiciaire d'une durée de
onze mois et 18 jours et administratives
ce n'est pas un cas isolé puisque une
quarantaine de djihadiste français ont
retrouvé la liberté depuis 2018 et
plusieurs dizaines d'autres devraient
être relâchés en 2020 la solution d'un
tribunal international ou du maintien
des jihadistes français en détention à
l'étranger pose question en effet le
contexte géopolitique de la région et le
délit
non de certains états ne permettent plus
de garantir que les terroristes ils
soient jugés et maintenu en détention
faute de solutions le rapatriement de
djihadiste français apparaît de plus en
plus comme une hypothèse envisageable
comme vous l'avez récemment rappelé
d'ailleurs la question du rapatriement
des terroristes français et de leurs
libéral de leur libération soulève le
problème de la récidive
comment s'assurer de l'absence de
dangerosité de ces individus une fois
libéré madame la garde des sceaux la
lutte contre la radicalisation est un
combat de longue haleine
face à de tels criminels notre arsenal
juridique est insuffisant comment
comptez vous y remédier afin d'assurer
la sécurité des français
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice madame bello mais vous avez la
parole monsieur le sénateur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
pardon monsieur le président mesdames
laissé un triste messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur au nom ville la
lutte contre la radicalisation et
terrorisme islamiste c'est évidemment
une des préoccupations majeures du
ministère de la justice
je considère que nous disposons des
outils juridiques qui nous permettent
d'y faire face efficacement quelques
mots d'abord pour vous dire que pour les
combattants qui reviennent des zones de
combat précisément les djihadistes sont
systématiquement judiciariser de manière
systématique à leur retour sur le sol
national et ils le sont par le nouveau
parc national antiterroriste que nous
avons créée il y a quelques mois ça se
traduit très concrètement par
l'engagement de poursuites du chef
d'association de malfaiteurs terroristes
qui conduit à des peines
d'emprisonnement qui lorsqu'il s'agit
des peines de nature criminelle peuvent
aller jusqu'à 20 ans de prison ce qui
est évidemment important à ce jour
224 revenant au fait l'objet de
poursuites et sont pour les trois quarts
d'entre eux au moment où je vous parle
aujourd'hui en détention dans des
établissements pénitentiaires et des
établissements qui sont adaptées à la
poursuite et à la prise en charge de
leur profil ils sont soit l isolement
soit dans des quartiers spécifiques
de prise en charge de la radicalisation
à leur sortie ils font l'objet d'un
suivi par un juge spécialisé spécialisés
et notamment ils sont soumis à des
obligations extrêmement strictes de
contrôle ils peuvent également être
prises en charge par l'un de nos centres
de jour que nous avons créés dans
différentes villes de france la loi site
prévoit également pour ces personnes-là
des mesures administratives de suivi et
de renseignement donc ils font l'objet
d'un double suivi à la fois judiciaires
et administratifs à leur sortie de
détention et notamment ils ont de ce
fait la démesure individuel de contrôle
et de surveillance avec notamment
l'obligation pointage l'interdiction de
quitter la commune est évidemment des
obligations de domiciliation fixe dans
le cas que vous citez monsieur flavien
moreau il est su soumis à cette double
obligations judiciaires et
administratives je voudrais vous assurer
au fond du sénateur que nous sommes
absolument vigilant en termes de
judiciarisation et de prise en charge de
ces personnes qui reviennent des
terrains de combat
merci pouvez vous nous dire si vous
pensez au delà de la déontologie
nécessaire à faire respecter que votre
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
qui avaient sonné comme un permis de se
lâcher à une responsabilité dans cette
situation où la liberté de manifester
est endommagé
que comptez vous faire pour que les
enquête de l'igpn sur les centaines de
cas dont elle a été saisie ne soit plus
enterré et que des sanctions exemplaires
soient prononcées en cas de manquement
allez vous continuer seul en europe à
mettre des ailes bd et des grenades
gleave f4 qui contient du tnt entre les
mains de ce qu'ils ont en face d'eux des
manifestants très largement pacifiques
et non pas des soldats ennemis ou des
terroristes
je ne leur dirai pas ce qui a été dit
par le président de la république par le
premier ministre par le ministre de
l'intérieur sur nécessaire exemplarité
des policiers je voudrais simplement
rappeler le contexte parce que
manifestement vous le perdez de jus vous
ne pouvez pas ignorer
monsieur le sénateur puisque ça a
commencé sous le quinquennat précédent
que nous avons à faire des
manifestations qui deviennent de plus en
plus vieux
entre souvenez-vous des manifestations
contre la loi les conneries nous avons
vécu avec les gilet jaune et nous vivons
actuellement avec la manifestation
contre le projet retraite en raison de
l'engagement de certaines mouvances
ultra des actions extrêmement violentes
qui vise à s'en prendre à nos
institutions à nos policiers de manière
extrêmement violente dégradation de
mobilier urbain dégradations de
commerces dans ces conditions que voulez
vous que fasse d'autres policiers et
gendarmes si ce n'est d'intervenir selon
une doctrine que nous avons revu avec
christophe castaner et que nous assumons
totalement et sachez qu'en europe
certaines polices en vie la façon dont
j'ai géré mon l'ordre public et pour ce
faire je veux simplement rendre hommage
à nouveau à l'ensemble de nos policiers
et nos gendarmes qui sont sur la voie
publique et vous je vous remercie
monsieur avoir bien voulu rendre hommage
à monsieur franck la bois qui a été
tuées le week-end dernier et qui nous
rappelle la dangerosité de la mission et
du métier de policier de gendarme
monsieur assouline eu quelques secondes
monsieur le président
vous savez que la grande majorité des
manifestants dont je parle sont
pacifiques les syndicalistes
je vois que la droite jeu je vois que la
droite le conteste et bien entendu je
condamne avec force les casseurs et je
pense que rendre hommage aux policiers
c'est condamner les dérives qui ont eu
lieu
[Musique]